BETH MEAGHER: One
of the things that I
think was the theme in
everyone's introduction
and area of focus is this whole
concept of interoperability.
There is a confluence of
events that is happening,
and it presents us with a
really unique opportunity
for changing from disease
state to really prediction.
And Andrea, I'd love to hear
a little bit about the data
strategy that you're
pulling together
and how that's going
to help further
the state of the future
of health concept.
ANDREA NORRIS: So NIH,
as we've been going down
this experiential
journey I call it
over the last few years
in our data science base,
and we just issued this past
year our first ever Data
Science Strategic Plan.
Trans NIH, trans
disease, trans domain,
and I would encourage
you to go on our website
and take a look at that.
But we identified
five key things.
We really are trying to
look to how we can best
leverage the tremendous
advances in technology
with our incredible scientific
expertise and research
expertise and harness that
in more powerful ways.
And that requires
some cultural change.
Historically, we fund about
300,000 researchers a year
at about 2,500 academic and
medical centers in our country,
and some cases globally.
And so researchers,
at a time, develop
their, collect their
data, analyze their data,
test their hypothesis,
store that data.
We have all of this
data resident anywhere
you can imagine, right,
someone's desktop,
someone's server, campus,
medical center, data center,
et cetera.
And we can't find it, we
can't access it easily.
We certainly can't interoperate
across various data domains
and data sets, and
we can't sustain it.
We can't reuse it.
So we're starting over
again, almost every time.
And so our strategic plan really
focuses on five key target
areas.
First and foremost is to
work more in partnership
with industry and
non-traditional partners, who
have the expertise, and
advances, and infrastructure
and compute.
We don't need to buy that
a researcher at a time.
We need to use that
researcher's time
to do the scientific
advancements,
not to figure out how to set up
my server and my data structure
and what tool I
need to use, right?
But the other is looking at
the algorithms and the tools.
We fund a great deal
of that, looking
at how we can educate and train
and orient our next generation,
scientific researchers, with
the tools and capabilities they
need to take advantage of these
new artificial intelligence,
machine learning,
these vast data sets.
Our big data set programs now
are in the 10s and 20s and 30
petabytes size ranges.
These are huge data sets.
We're moving all of these
to the commercial cloud.
We can't sustain
them locally anymore.
We want to bring the
researcher to the data
with relatively available
tools, with their own tools.
They can do compute
by themselves.
They can do it
with someone else.
They can leave what's there
for the next researcher, right?
And we believe that's
the model of the future.
And so we are trying a lot
of different approaches
and techniques,
including policies,
and other things for requiring
data management plans,
and having people think
about how they're going
to share and sustain that data.
But we believe that's how
we'll accelerate discovery
in ways we've never been
able to do in the past.
BETH MEAGHER: That's great.
Doug, I know that one of the
things that you have been
thinking about is
working with clients
to really look at archetypes.
What are the archetypes
in the future of health?
And I'd love to
hear your thoughts
on what are some
of the archetypes
that you think are really--
you're seeing a lot
more of your clients
talk about, and specifically
maybe some of the challenges?
DOUG BEAUDOIN: Yeah.
We've coined about 10
different archetypes,
and they range from, as
we talked about here, sort
of the data convener, the data
analyzer, the data manipulator,
and the interpreter as sort of
one end of the spectrum, all
the way through to how do we
finance this in an equitable
way, when, if you can predict
the risk of a population's
disease state or
wellness state, you know,
what is the role of
health insurance,
both catastrophic
and pooled insurance.
And so that kind of
individual financer
is a part of the future,
you know, the way
we buy health insurance could be
dramatically different, because
of the predictability
of a population
and predictability of yourself.
I think one of the
other themes that
has come out in
our point of view
around the future of
health, and it kind of
relates to the
concept of getting
the data to the researcher
in your environment,
we also talk about that
we, as individuals,
will own our own data and
own access to our own data,
meaning we will be
in the driver's seat,
not only of owning that
data that's either owned now
by a health plan, a research
organization, a health system,
a life sciences corporation.
But how do we create
that interoperability
so that we can own
it, and we can also
grant access to that data?
So another kind
of archetype would
be is the idea that the
individual will own the data
and therefore be able to
grant not only access to it,
but they can use their own
data to make some decisions,
especially if you can layer
on a cognitive AI layer
to get them access to the latest
and greatest clinical trials,
as an example.
Don't wait for the
hospitals to suggest it.
You know, be doing that kind
of shopping for yourself
for lack of a better
way to put it.
I think the only
other final element
that I'll talk
about that we talk
about a lot is the retailization
of health care in general.
I just got off the phone
with the CEO of a big health
system a few minutes ago.
And his point of view is what's
the role of the emergency
room in the future, where
health care is going retail
and that the
consumer is expecting
the same level of retail
experience interaction
that they do at their
very favorite restaurant
and retail situation and
other service providers.
So I think the whole
element of the retailization
and whether that becomes like
a health hub kind of concept,
or whether that becomes
a virtual concept,
meaning you get care wherever
you want to have care,
including in your
home, I think are
some of the major shifts
that were predicting.
BETH MEAGHER: That's great.
One of the things that
we've been thinking about
are some of the trends.
And Aashima, I know
when we've talked,
you've highlighted
some of the themes
around interoperability and the
connectivity to future health.
I'd love to hear from you.
What are the things that
you're excited about?
you're seeing specifically
from your role at Google Cloud?
AASHIMA GUPTA: So what we hear,
much of what we are building
comes from, what we
hear from our partners,
from the industry,
and how do we enable
Andrea and Cardinal Health and
a lot of industry stakeholders.
From the mission
perspective, Google
is a mission-oriented company.
You know us as a
consumer company.
And if you're
hearing our keynotes,
we are making our best
attempt, and we are really
engaging with enterprises
much more deeply.
For past 20 years, we have built
technology from the consumer
world that we are now making
it available to enterprises,
so truly democratization
of infrastructure,
democratization of
artificial intelligence,
and then democratization
of records,
which is the interoperability.
So our mission
statement from Google
is a very timeless
statement, which
is to make information
security accessible and useful.
In health care, our mission
is to enable enterprises
to really organize health
care information, make
it accessible, and useful.
And if I have to translate
that, when I say organize,
that means security compliance.
You need a platform to get the
data that Andrea talked about.
When we say accessible,
that's where
the interoperability comes in.
If the data is locked
up in a system--
and I'll give an example.
We are all consumers
of health care,
and this is an
example I use often.
How many health apps--
there's an app for everything.
There's a diabetic app.
How many apps do you think
exists in the app stores?
Any guesses?
Take a guess, like
50,000, 100,000.
It's not a billion yet.
The last I checked it
was like 250,000-plus.
Right, there's an
app for everything.
And now I'll ask
a second question.
How many of those
apps do you think
connect to your patient record?
Like 2%.
That's the opportunity, when
we as consumers are given
these tools, and we talk
about patient empowerment,
but if the glass
layer or the app
is not able to connect
to my patient record,
that's where accessibility
and interoperability comes in.
And then the third part is to
make the information useful,
that's where we are applying
AI and machine learning,
and we strongly believe to
apply AI machine learning
in health care where
the data is so diverse,
and the standards
like FHIR, HL7,
we are teaching a cloud to
speak language of health care.
How many folks here are
familiar with FHIR and HL7?
Well, this is the
health care crowd.
Great.
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah, so we want to speak--
we are teaching the cloud
from the cloud perspective.
Our engineering team,
our product team,
are focused on building
products solutions
to talk HL7, to talk FHIR
because we believe not only
that data normalization
will be important,
but this is a gateway to
apply AI machine learning,
because you don't want to
build models, which are working
on just one set of data.
That's where the standardization
and semantic interoperability
with FHIR becomes important.
And as I said before,
we all as a consumer
will benefit from it.
And how many folks have heard
of 21st Century Cures Act?
Well, so according to
[INAUDIBLE] by 2020,
if patients want
access to their data,
the provider systems
have responsibility
to give the data in
the form of an API.
It's coming down.
This started with
President Obama.
So that's where we
will now, as a patient,
that you were talking
about, have access
to our own data via API.
And the tools that we are
building is to enable that
and teaching those languages.
BETH MEAGHER: I
think that's great.
And Jon, I know you
have talked about how
Cardinal Health is using AI
and ML to help your business.
Would you share with
the audience how you're
thinking about it
now and in the future
and any learnings that you've
seen as you've implemented it?
JON LATSHAW: Yeah, I'd say we're
just at the beginning of it,
so I think a lot of companies
are in the same boat of,
how do we leverage this.
It's not as easy to
consume as we would hope.
So we have data
scientists on staff.
They're expensive.
We need more.
What we're hopeful is, with
Google, AutoML and developments
like that, where me-- and
I'm definitely not a data
scientist-- could
use it and say,
hey, give me some insights
out of this data pool.
I've got a whole set of
data, and I could almost
ask questions like in a
natural language query
or something like that.
I think it's coming, and I think
it'll be faster than we think.
But that's a little bit where
we're struggling right now.
We're getting some
benefit, but I
think it's nothing compared to
what we'll see in five years.
BETH MEAGHER: Any
immediate learnings
that you've seen as you've
started to implement?
JON LATSHAW: I'm not
familiar with that.
BETH MEAGHER: OK.
One of the things
that I think is
interesting with what
each of you have said
is really around ecosystems.
So there are many traditional
folks that you're working with,
and you'll continue.
But one of the
themes that I think
has come out in each of
your sort of future talks
about where the health market's
going is working with people
that are slightly different.
So Andrea, I'd love to hear--
I know you all at NIH are doing
some really interesting things
around sickle cell and
around rare diseases.
And I'd like to hear
a little bit more
about how these ecosystems
are playing out.
ANDREA NORRIS: Yeah,
so we've tended
to study by disease or by
data domain or data type.
And I'll share with you.
So 2003, we did the
Human Genome program.
That was $3 billion and took
decades, more than 10 years
to be able to
solve that problem.
That was 2003.
2010, just seven years later,
it was $10 million and months.
Now it's less than $1,000
and minutes to do this.
So in that same
window of time, we
saw the rise of the
electronic health record
and went from zero adoption
to almost full adoption.
But we haven't
figured out really
how to take advantage of that.
And incredible changes
in imaging data--
so MRI and scanning data.
So what we're seeing
is incredible advances
in discovery, in diseases that
we just could never deal with.
One of our programs, we have a
Precision Medicine Initiative.
We believe this is
a key way that we're
going to accelerate discovery.
We're looking for
a million cohorts.
And it's participants.
We literally changed
the language.
You're not a patient.
You're a participant in
the research journey.
You contribute your genome data,
your electronic health record,
your environmental data, so
we know your Fitbit data,
so we know about
you in your world,
in your history, how you
live, and about your health,
and along with a million other
cohorts, a very diverse people.
Now, why does that matter?
Think what you can do with
preliminary clinical trial
ideas if you have access
to that kind of rich data
across diverse over multiple
years that can accelerate
the billion dollars
and 10 years it
takes to get a healthy drug,
a successful drug to market.
There's like a 95% failure rate.
So if you can do
virtual clinical trials
in these rich data
sets, think how much
we can learn from that.
Alzheimer's-- every 66
seconds someone is diagnosed
in our country with Alzheimer's.
Just the time
we've been up here,
think how many people that is.
This is a crippling economic
and devastating disease
for our country.
And were looking not only in
how we can solve the problem,
treat the disease,
but also how we
can use computational
capabilities to predict well
in advance symptoms and
signs of people based
on their keyboarding skills,
based on their movement
and action, in home, in situ,
to help get you to the drugs
and treatments sooner.
We think sickle cell
is on the horizon.
We're going to have one of the
first HIV-free generations.
I believe, in my
lifetime, I will see that.
And so these diseases,
we can deal with them.
We may not be able
to resolve them all,
but we can treat them.
We can get treatments
to the market faster.
And it's this data, this merger
and intersection of the ability
to access data, to
have more participant,
person-centric health
in your health journey,
and the computational
capabilities, that is just--
it is game-changing.
Today a computer is as much
a scientific instrument
as a microscope
was 15 years ago.
And so it's an exciting future.
AASHIMA GUPTA: I think
I would add to that,
I think when you are talking
about artificial intelligence,
machine learning, maybe
I have a little more view
from the pragmatic
approach in health care,
even the connectivity
itself is a big issue.
AI is a next step,
but I submit to you,
if you don't have a
solid data strategy,
building an AI strategy, it's
not going to take you far.
So I'm good with
examples-- one more
example I'll share with you.
So let's say today, we all
talk about digital campaign,
reaching out to our consumer,
really helping them,
empowering them to take
care of their health.
So today, let's say if we
are running a query, maybe
on population health, where you
want to make an outreach to all
the females who are age from
45 to 50 who have a BRCA gene,
BRCA1 and BRCA2, had the
mammogram three years ago,
haven't checked into their
physician in the past 18
months.
There's no predictability here.
You're looking
backwards, and you
want to find out and make an
outreach to that population,
because they need to be come and
see and get the mammogram done.
How many folks here
in this room think
we can connect all these things
today and run such a query?
There's no AI here.
One person, OK?
Well, you sir are ahead.
Because why?
Because your imaging are living
in some PACS system in data
center.
Your health records are in HL7.
Your paying information,
what time it was due
is in your membership system.
How do you connect that?
And that's where the
cross-modality analytics
requires a platform
like cloud where you're
bringing in this data,
you're normalizing it,
and you're able to run those
queries to make that outreach
to your patient,
to your consumers,
to really help them with
their journey to be healthy.
And once you have a solid data
strategy, the data analytics,
you can really
build an AI layer.
What I worry now when I do
talk to a lot of customers,
oh, we want AI.
It's not a pixie dust.
Yes, we want AI, but you
really need a solid data.
And it is hard work.
It's mundane.
It's complicated.
And that's where we want
to help in taking and--
I call, I say
glorified plumbers,
to get those pipes to get
this data normalize it.
This is what Google is good at.
And make it easy
so that then you
can build your next level of
artificial intelligence tools
and do the good things
and innovate and build
those really empowering
capabilities.
BETH MEAGHER: I
think that's great.
And Doug, I'd love to
hear a little bit from you
around, when we think about
the archetypes, what archetype
do you see Deloitte playing
now and in the future?
DOUG BEAUDOIN: I would
say it's, in my opinion,
from a Deloitte perspective,
we have a unique situation
where we get the
opportunity to work
with many, many different parts
of the ecosystem that don't
normally play well together.
If you think about
retailers and health care,
it's not natural for
them to play together,
but we're seeing that.
The retailization of
health care is happening.
And we're in a unique way,
because we have the opportunity
to serve all the health
care organizations
and the government, plus
big retailers as well.
So driving that ecosystem,
play that integration.
Obviously many of those
retailers are making
plays themselves--
Aetna and CVS coming together.
I think we're going to
see the kind of burgeoning
retailization of health care
and those big retailers getting
into health care.
And in my opinion, bring it on.
I think we need to innovate.
I also think we have
this unique opportunity
to work with all of the really
important technology giants.
And again, we're here
talking about Google,
but in my opinion, bring it on.
The ability and the innovation
that the tech giants can bring
I think is a really,
really important element
to innovate health care way
faster than we've done before.
The third element that I think
is kind of a forgotten a little
bit element of our
health care system,
and that is the associations--
the Canadian Cancer--
or the American
Cancer Association--
you can tell I'm from Canada--
the MS Society.
And I think we're going to see
a new lease on life in the trust
factor that those
organizations have
had in a disease-specific
way and what role they
can play around data
sharing, providing insights.
There's some great
examples out there
where, for different
disease states,
the association is getting
together with Google,
as an example, and
creating that trust.
Again, the movement towards you
owning your data is happening,
we talked about.
But the movement towards you
sharing your data into a pool
to allow for greater
advancement and discovery
is a little bit
slower on the uptake.
And I think that the
associations play a really key
role, and we're helping kind
of stitch those partnerships
together.
BETH MEAGHER: That's great.
Interestingly, as you're all
talking about the future,
one thing is clear--
things are going
to be different.
And I'm curious, Jon, as you
start to think about the team
that you need to really move
forward, how does it look?
Does it look any different?
Are there different
skills that you're
going to need from the
workforce to help really
support your organization?
JON LATSHAW: Yeah, that's
going to change dramatically.
First, I want the pixie dust.
You guys should trademark
that right now--
just Pixie Dust AI.
Yeah, definitely.
I think everybody-- and
we're seeing this just
across all industries.
Everybody's becoming
a little bit
of a computer scientist, a
little bit of a data scientist.
It used to be,
there was the nerds,
and there was everybody else.
And the nerds would sit, and
they would stitch together
the computers, and
they'd write code.
But now everybody,
just every profession,
you have to learn at least
a little bit about computers
and data analytics.
We're dealing with this
at Cardinal Health in IT
as we shift to the cloud.
Everybody's like,
what should we learn?
And it's like, well, I
can't tell you exactly what,
but here's some good ideas,
things that won't ever
go out of style.
And I think that's
going to apply
to even professions-- lawyers,
doctors, medical professionals.
Everybody is going to have
to be a little more computer
literate.
BETH MEAGHER: That's great.
Andrea, you are the CIO of
one of the coolest missions
in the United States.
And we're here with
some great tech leaders.
What are some of
the things that you
would like to see from people
that are interested in working
at NIH, and why come to NIH?
ANDREA NORRIS: Yeah,
partnership, first of all--
we're looking for partners,
not providers, not here's
the answer to your problem
if you just buy this.
We really are in an
experiential journey.
That's what we do.
Research is a long-term
horizon, but we
want to make it more agile,
more facile, more adaptable,
and more expedient.
So we need people who are
committed to that mission, who
want to advance discovery and
accelerate discovery and help
for people all around the world.
And so I like to say,
NIH has a big footprint.
So whatever you do,
it might seem small,
but it has impacts
on people's lives
truly around the world
in ways that you'll
never, ever fully realize.
There's never a time that I
don't talk to groups like this
that someone doesn't
come up and say,
my mother was at the clinical
center, the world's largest
clinical research
hospital in the world,
and it was that research
that saved her life.
Or my son is in medical school
and was funded and supported
by the National
Institutes of Health
and trained under those dollars.
Health is personal, right?
It's your health, your family's
health, your children's health.
There's nothing
more precious to us
than our health and well-being.
So it is such an
honor to be at NIH,
and it is such an
exciting time to be there.
We are looking--
traditionally, we hired--
they called them the
wet lab researchers--
bioinformatics people,
biologists, chemistry.
What we know about the
biological system in health
is so small compared
to what we need
to know, after all of these
years and all of this time.
And so now we need data
scientists, we need engineers,
we need technologists,
we need communicators,
we need that kind
of team science
to really help integrate and
merge some of these ideas.
That's where the
discovery's going to be.
It's not going to be in
the traditional vertical.
There will still be
discoveries there,
but the ones that
will be game-changing
are going to come from
this cross-fertilization
and diversity of experience,
background, and perspectives.
We believe that very strongly.
BETH MEAGHER: Aashima, maybe one
question before we open it up
to the audience.
We've talked a lot about data.
We've talked about
interoperability.
I'd like to hear your
views on security
and the things that are
sort of top of mind for you
in that regard.
AASHIMA GUPTA: That's
a great question.
And before I answer that, having
come from the Kaiser world
and having built those systems--
I know legacy is a bad word,
but I'm still going to use it.
These systems that have been
built in the health care
assume the patient to
be in the facility.
If I got sick, I went
and saw the doctor,
be [? TR, ?] be my
primary care physician.
That paradigm has
changed on its head.
Now people are expecting
care where they are,
but the systems are not designed
to be accessed from outside.
When you talk
about ecosystem, we
are talking about telehealth,
we're talking about e-visits.
All the systems that
have been in place,
they served a purpose when
the people were visiting
physically in that facility.
And now when we're moving to
care-where-you-are paradigm,
that security layer
becomes very important.
People don't know how
to open the systems.
How do you do single sign-on?
What is an OAuth?
These are basic
skills, and we want
to meet the industry
where they are.
And building a lot of
security-based portfolio,
it's super important to us.
Google Cloud is HIPAA
compliant, but we are all
building new in
brand capabilities,
and HIPAA security is the
paradigm there-- like security,
auditability, who has
access to your system
when you're talking
about partners.
So that becomes one part.
The second part I would say
is focusing on the innovation
and letting the
infrastructure be--
I would say for Google Cloud.
But that's where we want to
align our [? course ?] trends
and provide value
to the industry.
So if you are passionate
about racking and stacking
and designing the tips of the
infrastructure, join Google.
But I would want you
to really work on,
how do you build those
capabilities on this world
class infrastructure,
because that's
where the democratization
will come from.
So don't solve to solve
problems, is my message to you.
Solve the problem that our
patients need, like we need,
like consumers need.
And the problems
that have been solved
by the big tech or
the infrastructure,
we take security very seriously.
We have hundreds of
security engineers,
and they're experts
in their field, that
are available to you now.
And that's where the true
democratization comes in.
And the third thing
I would say is,
cloud is not just a
lift and shift strategy,
and I do see that even today.
It's truly transformation.
It's a means to an end.
If you've just taken a
server from your on-premise
and moved to the
cloud, that's not
what this
transformation is about.
It's truly looking into the
business transformation,
looking into, like in this
care-where-you-are paradigm,
getting that out there, and
cloud be that means to the end.
And you define the
end, your strategy.
That's where we need to get to.
BETH MEAGHER: I
think that's great.
And Andrea, I know this is
really important to you.
Anything to add on
the security front?
ANDREA NORRIS: No, I just
think, in the research world,
one of the things that's really
important for us is that we
protect the data, not just for
security and privacy reasons,
but to honor the
consent agreement
by which you consent to give
your very important data to be
used for research purposes.
And we build those controls
then to honor that consent.
It may be that I
only want it used
if it's federal funded and
not for a profit entity,
or if it's in particular
areas of study.
And so that's a
level of complexity
that we've been dealing
with, and particularly
as these data sets have
gotten so big, and one
that we continue to work on.
Our studies and
surveys and work has
found that people are
very willing to contribute
their data for
the bigger cause--
my health, the betterment
of people around the world.
But they want the assurance
that my privacy, what
I'm consenting this data
for, is going to be protected
and that there
won't be any issues
with it being used for purposes
other than what I give it.
And that's something we spend
a lot of time and effort
and money trying to
make sure we honor that.
We're absolutely
committed to that,
because that's what is
reasonable and should
be what people should expect.
And I think as we
move more towards
this participant-managed, you're
managing your health care,
your health profile,
that's going to continue
to be even more important.
BETH MEAGHER: So I would
love to hear one word that
makes you kind of summarize
the future of health,
that describes what you're
thinking as the future comes,
Andrea.
DOUG BEAUDOIN: Here you go.
Sorry.
ANDREA NORRIS: Optimistic.
AASHIMA GUPTA: Empowering.
JON LATSHAW: I was going
to say optimistic, but--
BETH MEAGHER: And empowering.
JON LATSHAW: Hopeful.
DOUG BEAUDOIN: I'm
going to say wellness.
BETH MEAGHER: Wellness.
So thank you.
Incredible dialogue, thank you.
Great job.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]